[Music]
[Applause]
what is up guys before we get started
into the video I wanted to say that yes
I have done this video before so if you
want to see how to do this in detail go
ahead and click that video I'll leave it
in the description and also that old
video wasn't as much profit as this
video that's why I made this new one the
uncut Dragon stone is something that I
always watch out for and normally it is
not this high but right now it's going
for almost 23k and that's when you want
to do this method so do this method when
the dragon stone is anywhere between 20
to 23k and if it's even more even more
profit all right guys let's get started
into the video so if you haven't watched
my last video to summarize this
basically what you do you buy the tooth
half and the loop half for the cheapest
price that you can and then you put them
together and then you bring about six of
them or seven I use seven later on and
then you go ahead and teleport to your
house which you want to move to Taverly
which is super low requirement it's like
21 construction or something I'll leave
it in the description and then you run
into this house and you use the keys on
the chest
go ahead and make it so you teleport
outside your house I do that later in
this video and so basically what you get
you get a dragon Stone every time but
there's a chance of getting Rune bars
which is what you want Rune plate legs
which is what you want and coal which is
what you want you also get runes spinach
roll and a bunch of other things also
have your ring of dueling and teleport
to the castle Wars not Clan Wars like I
messed up and then go ahead and bank and
restart by teleporting to your house so
quick example of some good items to get
from the chest that you want to get I
got runite bars and run plate legs
that'll add up up I also started a timer
so I'll show you guys how long this
takes all right I am almost done I am
now just running back to the house and
I'm bringing my ring of wealth so I can
teleport to the Grand exchange for the
last inventory I used 10 keys so I knew
some items would be on the ground but
that's okay I just ran back and picked
them up and it looks like we're going to
land on exactly 20 minutes so it took 20
minutes to do all this didn't take long
at all and let's go see how much profit
we made all right I took out all the
items now I will price check them I
spent about 4 mil so let's see how much
we made but bro
what I spent 4 mil and I got 1.3
mil
what oh no wait I forgot the dragon
Stones so my dumbass forgot to put the
dragon stones in there so now I will
take them out and I have 151 because I
put together one of the keys because I
got two key parts to make a key okay 4.7
mil that makes more sense I'll go ahead
and write down the total down here so I
have it to see if we make anything close
to
that so now I will go ahead and sell the
items
[Music]
okay so I sold everything and I made
4,719 th000 that's only about 10,000 off
from the OS buddy price so that's pretty
good now I will do the calculations and
figure out how much money we make per
hour so I figured out the math how much
it cost to buy the tooth Hales and the
loop halves and I put it down there on
the bottom so you guys can see so now I
will put the total price
4,719 74 from what we made minus what
the two half's cost 2,670
th000 minus the loop half cost 1,
635,000 so 413k is what we made in 20
minutes so we'll go ahead and times that
by 3 cuz 60 minutes divided by 20 is 3
so 1.2 mil keep in mind that I probably
made more than 50k which is the amount
of coins I said I made from the chest so
it's probably more than 1.2 mil but this
is a safe guess all right guys thanks
for watching and stay tuned for my next
video